[تصفيق]
وين الهوايه وين
الهوايه قص مدفعي
خص مدفعي لمجموعه من المواطنين حسبي الله
ونعم
الوكيل حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل حسبي الله
شهداء عشرات الشهداء عشرات من الشهداء في
جريمه ضد
الانسانيه عشرات الشهداء في جريمه ضد
الانسانيه مجموعه من المواطنين كما
تشاهدون الان شهيد اخر شهيد اخر شهيد
اخر حسبنا الله
الوكيل حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل اكثر من ع
شهداء في قذيفه واستهداف استهداف مواصل
بحق المواطنين في هذا المكان هذا هو مكان
القذيفه هذا هو مكان
القذيفه جريمه تشر لها الابناء في حق
الانسانيه شهداء بالعشرات
كما
تشاهدون هذا مكان بالقرب من الهلال الاحمر
هذا المكان بالقرب من الهلال
الاحمر شهداء اخرين شهداء شهداء اخرين
الان هنا كذلك كما نشاهد هذه جريمه الحق
الانسانيه قصف مدفع
متواصل ابو
علي سوف نغادر المكان المكان لا يسمح
المكان لا يسمح بالتواجد به هنا القصف
المدفعي كما نشاهد في في كل
مكان قصف المدفعي في كل
مكان قصف المدفع في كل مكان قصف المدفع في
كل مكان
يا شبابو في النص يا عم علوش في النص
اشلاء في هذا القصف المدفعي ضد المواطنين
الان شهيد الان شهيد اخر الان شهيد
اخر حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل جميعهم شهداء
جميعهم
شهداء جميعهم
شهداء ما في واحد طلع
جريح تداعيات استهداف مجموعه من المواطنين
في قصف مدفعي على حي الامل بالقرب من
جمعيه الهلال الان طائرات الكواد كابتر
تطلق النار على المواطنين كما تشاهدون
الان طائرات كوات كبتر
تطلق
الرصاص المكان صعب التواجد به كما
تشاهدون
بابا و
بابا المواطنين الذين تم استهدافهم طبعا
هم من النازحون في الهلال الاحمر هم من
النازحون في الهلال
الاحمر المكان خطر جدا كما
تشاهدون مكان خطر جدا بالرغم من الاستهداف
المباشر بقذائف الدبابات مازالت طائرات
الوات كابت تطلق النار على المواطنين في
هذا المكان في هذا
المكان الشارع حتى اللحظه الزائف في نفس
الشارع ما زالت طبعا مستمره في نفس
الشارع طيران طيران طائره تطلق الرصاص في
نفس
الشارع نفس المكان الذي تم استهداف فيه
المواطنون يتم استهداف ف عده
[موسيقى]
واح